The boat travels at 25 miles per hour, great algebra solving if you found that
answer. We know the lowest common denominator for this equation would be x
minus 5 times x plus 5. So, we multiply our equation through by the LCD. These
binomials cancel with one another, leaving us with this equation. Here on the
right hand side I recognize that this was the difference of squares pattern. So
I just have x squared minus 25 a squared minus b squared. Next we distribute to
get this equation. Now we just want to combine my terms. 10 x plus 15 x equals
25 x. And positive 50 minus 75 equals negative 25. Next we add 25 to both sides
or just remove the negative 25 since it's balanced on each side of the
equation. This leaves us with 25 x Eequal to x squared. We have a quadratic
equation, so we want to move this term to the other side, with the positive x
squared term. This allows us to set our equation, equal to 0. Now we're in a
position to factor this quadratic. I've rewritten it here, and then I factored
an x out of each of these terms. So I'll have x times x minus 25. Now we set
each factor equal to 0, leaving us with x equals 0, or x equals 25. So there
are actually two possible values for x, 25 or 0. But since the boat is actually
moving, we know it can't be zero. Therefore, the boat must move at 25 miles per
hour in still water.